Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. I can't spell it right. So you just give a fake name, your cafe name, Julia. But the more you use it, the more it feels like you're in witness protection. Wait a minute. What kind of espresso drinks does Julia like anyway? Is it too late to change your latte order? But with an espresso machine by KitchenAid, you wouldn't be thinking any of this because you could have just made your espresso at home.
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需每周收听额外剧集、享受无广告体验、抢先观看系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。我总是拼不对。所以你随便报个假名，比如咖啡馆里的名字，朱莉娅。但你用得越多，就越觉得自己在接受证人保护。等等。朱莉娅到底喜欢喝什么样的浓缩咖啡？现在改点拿铁还来得及吗？但如果你有一台 KitchenAid 浓缩咖啡机，你就不会有这些烦恼了，因为你完全可以在家自制浓缩咖啡。
Shop now at KitchenAid.ca. In the 3rd century, a Turkish Roman soldier joined a growing cult and was executed for it, inspiring other martyrs. When the cult later became the official religion of the Roman Empire, the soldier inspired a popular cult of his own in Palestine. The empire persisted as a religious power structure in Europe and the Middle East, and many churches were dedicated to that Turkish soldier right across the territory of the old empire,
立即前往 KitchenAid.ca 选购。公元 3 世纪，一位土耳其裔罗马士兵加入了一个日益壮大的教派，并因此被处决，从而激励了其他殉道者。当该教派后来成为罗马帝国的官方宗教时，这位士兵在巴勒斯坦也激发了一个广受欢迎的崇拜。帝国作为一种宗教权力结构在欧洲和中东延续了下来，许多教堂在旧帝国的领土上都供奉着这位土耳其士兵，
from the Levant in the east to Britain in the west. The military cults became associated with orders of knighthood across Europe in the Middle Ages. When England split away from the church still run from Rome, all banners of saints except for that of the Turkish soldier were banned. He was just too popular. At some point, a myth about dragon slayer became attached to that soldier. He became adopted as the patron saint of many territories he never set foot in. Georgia, Ethiopia, Aragon and Catalonia, Portugal, Brazil, Bulgaria, Moscow, Serbia and Montenegro and England. Tom, that was a top faith leader, the former president of the humanists, no less, Professor Alice Roberts, writing on the website formerly known as Twitter on the 23rd of April 2021. So she was writing, Tom, on the feast day of the most famous dragon slayer of all, wasn't she?
从东方的黎凡特到西方的英国。在中世纪，这些军事崇拜与欧洲各地的骑士团联系在一起。当英国脱离仍由罗马管理的教会时，除了这位土耳其士兵的旗帜外，所有圣徒的旗帜都被禁止了。他实在太受欢迎了。在某个时期，关于屠龙者的神话被附会到了这位士兵身上。他被许多他从未踏足过的地区奉为守护圣徒。格鲁吉亚、埃塞俄比亚、阿拉贡和加泰罗尼亚、葡萄牙、巴西、保加利亚、莫斯科、塞尔维亚和黑山，以及英国。汤姆，那是顶级信仰领袖，前人道主义者协会主席，爱丽丝·罗伯茨教授，于 2021 年 4 月 23 日在曾经被称为推特的网站上写下的。所以，汤姆，她是在最著名的屠龙者的圣日那天写的，对吧？
Absolutely. St. George. So we did a previous episode on dragons, didn't we? But we didn't mention him. And that's because I think he deserves an episode all to himself. He's a saint who is also an archetype, an archetype of courage, of good overcoming evil. So one of the countries that Alice Roberts didn't mention in that list of territories that have St. George as their patron saint was Malta. And Malta, Dominic, is one of three countries in the world to feature a dragon on its flag. So do you know the other two?
绝对是。圣乔治。我们之前做过一期关于龙的节目，对吧？但我们没有提到他。那是因为我觉得他值得拥有一期专门的节目。他既是一位圣徒，也是一个原型，一个勇气和正义战胜邪恶的原型。所以，爱丽丝·罗伯茨在提到那些以圣乔治为守护圣徒的地区名单时，漏掉了一个国家，那就是马耳他。多米尼克，马耳他是世界上三个国旗上有龙的国家之一。你知道另外两个吗？
Wales, of course, Wales. Wales is one. And I'm going to go with somewhere like Bhutan. Correct. Very good. Oh my gosh. Was it Bhutan? So you have won the pub quiz.
威尔士，当然是威尔士。威尔士是一个。我猜另一个是像不丹这样的地方。正确。非常好。天哪。真的是不丹吗？那你赢得了酒吧问答比赛。
That's excellent. Wow. So people often get those two, but Malta as well, because the flag of Malta has the George Cross on the top side of it. Of course it does. Yeah. And the George Cross, of course, it's the highest honour for courage, isn't it? Yeah. That's awarded to civilians. So for acts
太棒了。哇。人们经常猜对那两个，但马耳他也是，因为马耳他国旗的顶部有乔治十字勋章。当然有。是的。乔治十字勋章，当然，它是勇气的最高荣誉，不是吗？是的。它是授予平民的。所以是为了
of the greatest heroism or for most conspicuous courage in circumstances of extreme danger. And it was famously given to Malta in 1942 to mark its heroism during the siege of it in the Second World War. And it was then incorporated into its flag the following year. And even after independence
最伟大的英雄行为，或者在极端危险的情况下表现出的最显著的勇气。它于 1942 年被授予马耳他，以纪念其在第二次世界大战围城期间的英雄主义。次年，它被纳入了国旗。即使在独立之后，
the Maltese were so proud of it that they kept it. Yeah. Love Malta. And in the middle of that St. George cross, you have this emblem of St. George on his horse riding down a dragon. And obviously, Tom, the reason he's there is not just because, you know, lots of kings called George. It's because St. George has become the embodiment of heroism, courage. It's why English kings in Shakespearean plays or sort of sub-Shakespearean films draw their sword and cry, God for Harry, St. George and England, as they ride to smite the French.
马耳他人也为之感到自豪，所以他们保留了它。是的，爱马耳他。在那个乔治十字勋章的中间，有圣乔治骑在马上刺杀龙的徽章。显然，汤姆，他出现在那里不仅仅是因为，你知道，很多国王叫乔治。这是因为圣乔治已经成为英雄主义和勇气的化身。这就是为什么莎士比亚戏剧或类似莎士比亚风格电影中的英国国王在骑马去打击法国人时，会拔出剑大喊：“为了哈里，为了圣乔治，为了英国！”
Well, Dominic, I mean, you remember we did an episode on the founding of the Order of the Garter. And specifically in the context of the Hundred Years' War, the king who's really into St. George is Edward III, who institutes the Order of the Garter in 1344. And he does it on the 23rd of April. And there are various saints who are patrons of the Order. So there's the Virgin Mary, there's St. Edmund, the king of East Anglia who got feathered by Viking arrows, and there's Edward the Confessor. But there's the Virgin Mary, there's St. Edmund, the King of East Anglia who got feathered by Viking arrows, and there's Edward the Confessor. But there's no question that St. George is the most important of those patrons. And that's why it's badge. You have a garter encircling the arms
嗯，多米尼克，我的意思是，你记得我们做过一期关于嘉德勋章创立的节目。特别是在百年战争的背景下，真正推崇圣乔治的国王是爱德华三世，他在 1344 年设立了嘉德勋章。他是在 4 月 23 日设立的。勋章有几位守护圣徒。有圣母玛利亚，有被维京人箭矢射成刺猬的东盎格利亚国王圣埃德蒙，还有忏悔者爱德华。但毫无疑问，圣乔治是这些守护圣徒中最重要的一位。这就是为什么它是徽章。你有一个环绕着
of St. George, which famously it's a red cross on a kind of white background. And its very first seal showed Edward III kneeling before St. George, who is clad in the armor of a knight. Inspiring. Very inspiring, Tom. Yeah, absolutely inspiring. And there's no question, I guess, that particularly the figure of George on a horse killing a dragon, I would say is one of the most familiar visual representations of a saint. You know, no matter where, everyone would recognize is one of the most familiar visual representations of a saint. You know, no matter where, everyone would recognize that pretty much. But I think it's also true to say that if the 23rd of April, St. George's Day, is a celebration of courage and of
圣乔治纹章的嘉德带，众所周知，那是白色背景上的红色十字。它的第一个印章显示爱德华三世跪在身穿骑士盔甲的圣乔治面前。鼓舞人心。非常鼓舞人心，汤姆。是的，绝对鼓舞人心。毫无疑问，我想，特别是骑在马背上杀龙的乔治形象，我认为它是圣徒最广为人知的视觉表现之一。你知道，无论在哪里，每个人几乎都能认出那个形象。但我认为同样可以说，如果 4 月 23 日圣乔治日是对勇气和
the triumph of good over evil, it's also very much become a festival of scoffing, one might say. Some people might even say sneering, Tom. Possibly, yes. So on Twitter, every April the 23rd, it's part of the festivities that people go and say he didn't exist and he didn't fight a dragon and so on. Well, the Turkish soldier business. All of that, yes. But the thing is, this is not a recent phenomenon at all.
正义战胜邪恶的庆祝，它也确实在很大程度上变成了一个嘲讽的节日，人们可能会这么说。有些人甚至可能会说是冷嘲热讽，汤姆。可能吧，是的。所以每年的 4 月 23 日，在推特上，人们去说他不存在，他没有杀龙等等，这已经成为庆祝活动的一部分。嗯，关于那个土耳其士兵的事情。所有这些，是的。但问题是，这根本不是什么近期的现象。
I mean, it has a very, very long history. And so Alice Robertson, that said that St. George was spared being banned in the Reformation. This is not a recent phenomenon at all. It has a very, very long history. Alice Robertson said that St. George was spared being banned in the Reformation. Actually he wasn't. There were definite moves to get rid of St. George from radical Protestants. Of course, the king who rules over the Reformation at its most radical is Edward VI, the son of Henry VIII. Under him, the associations of the VIII. And under him,
我的意思是，它有着非常非常悠久的历史。所以爱丽丝·罗伯茨说圣乔治在宗教改革中免于被禁。这根本不是什么近期的现象。它有着非常非常悠久的历史。爱丽丝·罗伯茨说圣乔治在宗教改革中免于被禁。其实他并没有。激进的新教徒确实有明确的举动要除掉圣乔治。当然，在宗教改革最激进时期统治的国王是爱德华六世，亨利八世的儿子。在他统治下，嘉德勋章与圣乔治的联系被明确禁止了。在 1551 年 4 月 23 日于格林威治举行的盛大嘉德宴会上，有一个非常像推特上人道主义者的时刻。爱德华六世，就像他在推特上冷嘲热讽一样，问所有聚集的嘉德勋爵：“我的勋爵们，我请问你们，圣乔治是哪位圣徒，以至于我们在这里如此尊崇他？”然后他的财务官回答他，谈论他杀死了龙，万岁。爱德华就笑得前仰后合。
the associations of the Order of the Garter with St. George were explicitly banned. And there's a kind of very humanists on Twitter moment in 1551 at the great garter feast on the 23rd of April is held at Greenwich. And Edward VI, very much as though he's having a sneer on Twitter, he asks all the assembled lords of the garter, my lords, I pray you, what saint is St. George that we here so honor him? And then its treasurer answers him by talking about, you know, that he slew the dragon, hurrah. And Edward just collapses into fits of giggling.
是的。他说，哦，真的吗？好吧，把剑给我看看。所以他在扮演怀疑论者。我一直觉得爱德华六世身上有一种极其令人难以忍受的东西，我很高兴我的怀疑得到了证实。是的，我的意思是，他身上有一种稍微有点自命不凡的特质。但当然，他是宗教改革最怀疑教皇崇拜的狂热支持者，多米尼克。
Yeah. And he says, oh, really? Well, show me the sword. So he is playing the skeptic. I always thought there was something deeply insufferable about Edward VI, and I'm glad to have my suspicions confirmed. Yeah, I mean, there was kind of slightly priggish quality to him. But of course, he's an enthusiastic proponent of the Reformation at its most skeptical of papist mummery, Dominic.
嗯，他被唤醒了，汤姆，不是吗？他被福音派的火焰唤醒了，所以他字面上是“觉醒”的（woke）。是的，他被唤醒了，这就是为什么在 1553 年，也就是他去世的那一年，但他 4 月 23 日还在世，嘉德勋章与圣乔治的联系被斥为晦涩、迷信和令人反感的观点。是的，所以激进的新教徒，我的意思是，整个乔治杀龙的故事，他们认为那是胡说八道。谁能想到人道主义者和激进的新教徒会有这么多共同点？这是《历史的余味》中从未提出过的观点。要是有人能写一本关于这个的书就好了。但问题就在这里。这就是最耐人寻味的地方。对圣乔治的怀疑不仅仅是新教徒的。因为在 5 世纪末，据说有一位教皇
Well, he has been awakened, Tom, hasn hasn't he he's been awakened by the fire of evangelicalism so he's literally woke yes he has been awakened and this is why in 1553 which is the year he will die but he's still around on the 23rd of april the links of the garter to saint george are dismissed as obscure superstitious and repugnant opinions yeah so radical protestants i mean the whole george killing a dragon, they thought that was nonsense. Who would ever have imagined that humanists and radical Protestants would have so much in common? It's a point that's never been made on the residence history. If only someone could write a book about this. But here's the thing. This is what's so intriguing. The doubts about St. George are not just Protestant. Because at the end of the fifth century a pope is said to
担心过完全相同的事情。所以教皇格拉西乌斯一世，他在 490 年代担任教皇，我的意思是，他基本上说这些故事全是疯话。而且在这一点上，他甚至不是在担心龙，他是在担心关于圣乔治的最基本的故事，对吧？他说这些全是伪造的，因此这些不应在罗马圣教会中阅读，以防给任何人哪怕一丝嘲笑它们的机会。就好像他在期待 21 世纪的社交媒体一样。事实上，只要圣乔治受到庆祝，就一直有人说，我们对他一无所知。关于他的故事都是疯话。现在，公平地说，格拉西乌斯实际上并没有怀疑乔治是否存在。而且他确实，嗯，在这个归于他的东西里，我们一会儿再看他是否真的说了，但他确实说乔治确实位列那些光荣斗争比人类更被上帝所知的圣徒之一。但我认为这反映了基督教学者想要剔除糟粕的愿望。认为证据必须经过压力测试，当有明显伪造或疯狂的东西时，你应该除掉它们，这不仅仅是一种新教徒或人道主义者的做法。我的意思是，这是贯穿基督教历史的一个主题。当然，如果你是一个反教权的人，一个反基督教的人，这并不完全符合你对基督教的版本，即基督教全是疯狂、迷信、堕落等等。你可以理解为什么这
have worried about exactly the same thing so pope galatius the first who was pope in the 490s i mean he basically said these stories are all mad and at this point he wasn't even worrying about the dragon he was kind of worrying about the most basic stories told about saint george right and he said that they were all bogus and therefore these are not read in the Holy Church of Rome to deny anyone even the slightest opportunity to sneer at them. It was as though he was looking forward to social media in the 21st century. Actually, as long as St. George has been celebrated, there have been people who've said, we don't know anything about him. The stories that are being told about him are mad. Now, it's fair to say that Galatius is not actually doubting that George existed. And he does, well, in this thing that is attributed to him, we'll see whether he actually said it in
可能没有得到关注。对于基督教的批评者来说，说“其实他们比我们想象的更怀疑”并不是那么令人情感满足。嗯，我的意思是，新教徒想嘲笑天主教徒，人道主义者想嘲笑新教徒，但我认为他们都是同一传统的一部分，这正是它如此有趣的原因。但显然，在 21 世纪甚至 16 世纪，对圣徒的历史性进行压力测试，要比在罗马帝国崩溃中的拉丁西方容易得多。我的意思是，那是一个真正的挑战。所以格拉西乌斯在罗马担任教皇时，西方的帝国已经完全崩溃了。你如何确定哪些来源是可靠的？
a minute, but he says that George does rank as one of the saints whose glorious struggles are known better to God than to human beings. But I think it reflects a desire on the part of Christian scholars to kind of winnow out the chaff. It's not just a kind of a Protestant or a humanist thing to imagine that evidence has to be stress tested and that when there are things that are obviously bogus or mad, you should get rid of them. I mean, this is something that has been a theme throughout Christian history. And of course, if you're an anti-clerical kind of person, an anti-Christian person, that doesn't quite fit into your version of Christianity, where Christianity is all mad, superstitious, depraved and whatnot. You can understand why this doesn't
我的意思是，归于格拉西乌斯的这些观点实际上似乎根本不是他写的，这非常有说明意义。大多数学者认为，它们可能是大约 50 年后在加尔写下的。这是一个真正的问题，因为当然，教会的一切都与奇迹有关。我的意思是，基督教教义的核心是某种定义上超自然、奇幻、不仅仅局限于世俗可能性范围的东西。但与此同时，你又不希望出现那些看起来太奇迹以至于
get the attention, maybe. It's not as emotionally satisfying for Christianity's critics to say, actually, they are more sceptical than we thought. Well, I mean, Protestants want to sneer at Catholics and humanists want to sneer at Protestants, but I think they're all part of the same tradition, which is what makes it so interesting. But obviously it's much easier to kind of stress test the historicity of a saint in the 21st century or even the 16th century than it was in the Latin West amid the implosion of the Roman Empire. I mean, that's a real challenge. So Galatius is Pope in Rome at a time when the empire in the West has completely imploded. And how do you work out what sources are reliable?
看起来荒谬的东西。很难知道该在哪里划清界限，汤姆。是的。我认为关于乔治最迷人的地方，也许比任何其他圣徒都更迷人的是，他是一个比任何其他圣徒都更能成为故事焦点的圣徒，这些故事引导了一种在公众舆论中根深蒂固的深层需求。也许正是因为这个原因，他从 5 世纪一直到 21 世纪都被知识精英所怀疑。
I mean, it's absolutely telling that actually these opinions that are attributed to Galatius actually don't seem to have been written by him at all. They were probably, I think most scholars think, written by someone writing in Gaul about 50 years later. And it's a real problem because, of course, the church is all about the miraculous. I mean, at the heart of Christian teaching is the idea of something that is, by definition, supernatural and fantastical and not merely bounded by the limits of kind of earthly possibility. But at the same time, you don't want things that might seem kind of so miraculous that
那么让我们开始吧。在开头的信仰领袖引言中，3 世纪，一位土耳其裔罗马士兵加入了一个教派。我们甚至能追溯到 3 世纪吗？我的意思是，他很可能生活在 3 世纪，但如果他真的生活过，关于他的故事是在 200 年后才首次讲述的。或者说是来源。是的。巨大的问题是我们没有任何与乔治同时代的来源，如果他真的生活过的话。我认为这是古代晚期的天主教作家所意识到并正在努力解决的问题，但同样我认为乔治受欢迎的原因是他就像一个湖泊，各种各样的
they seem ridiculous. It's hard to know whether to draw the line, Tom. Yeah. And I think the thing that's fascinating about George, maybe more than any other saint, is that he is the saint who perhaps more than any other one becomes a focus for stories that channel a very, very deep need that is kind of running deep in popular opinion. And for that very reason, perhaps, is kind of viewed with suspicion by the intellectual elites, you know, from the 5th century right the way up to the 21st.
流行故事流向这里。是的，他关注的第一个焦点不是屠龙，而是作为殉道者。对于罗马世界的基督徒来说，殉道者是教会的突击队，他们是最神圣的，他们是不必等待最后的审判就能进入天堂的人，他们直接去那里，他们坐在上帝的宴席桌旁。是的，所以关于乔治殉道的故事把所有熟悉的元素都拿来，并把它们提升到了一个巨大的高度。所以这些故事，这些来自 5 世纪，正如你所说，在乔治应该生活的时间之后大约 200 年，细节上有所不同，但你可以区分出一个基本轮廓。他们说的是乔治可能来自
So let's get to it. In that opening faith leader quote, the 3rd century, a Turkish Roman soldier joined a cult. Can we even get back as far as the 3rd century? I mean, he may well have lived in the third century, but if he did, the stories about him are first told 200 years later. Or the sources, rather. Yeah. The huge problem is we have no sources that are contemporaneous with a George if he lived. And I think that that is something that Catholic writers in late antiquity are aware of and are wrestling but equally i think the reason for george's popularity is that he's like a kind of lake into which all kinds of streams
卡帕多西亚，也就是现在土耳其的中心地带，但当然那时还不是土耳其。所以乔治不是土耳其人。乔治不可能是土耳其人。我的意思是，土耳其人在几千英里外的中亚草原上。当然。所以乔治是希腊人。乔治是一个希腊名字。是的。Gorgios。关于他实际上是在哪里长大的，有各种各样的传统。所以有一个传统源于最近在搬迁纪念碑以建造阿斯旺大坝时发现的一份手稿。在其中，乔治是在努比亚长大的。但来源一致的是，他在帝国服务中地位很高，也许是一名公务员。但成为某种正统的普遍传统是，他是一名士兵，是一名
of popular stories flow yeah and the first thing that he's a focus for isn't dragon slaying but for having been a martyr and martyrs for christians you know in the roman world are the kind of the shock troops of the church they are the holiest they are the people who don't have to wait around for the final judgment to get to heaven they go straight there they're seated at the feasting table of god yeah so the stories that are told about george's martyrdom kind of take all the familiar elements and kind of crank them up to a massive pitch so the stories that are told and these are from the fifth century so as you said about 200 years after after George is supposed to have lived, they vary in the details, but you can kind of distinguish a basic outline. And what they say is that George is probably from
在凯撒军队中作战的战士。所以无论哪种方式，都是帝国的伟大机构之一。是的。所以要么是公务员，要么是军队，他与军队联系在一起。他受洗，然后被一位异教皇帝命令向阿波罗献祭。他拒绝了，然后他遭受的折磨极其可怕，以至于近乎滑稽。在乔治故事的一个版本中，他被迫穿上里面有铁钉的鞋子，他的头骨被压碎，然后被钉入 60 颗钉子，然后为了保险起见，他被灌下熔化的铅。他此时还活着。
Cappadocia, which is in the middle of what is now Turkey, but of course wasn't Turkey then. So George was not a Turk. There's no way George could have been a Turk. I mean, the Turks are like thousands of miles away on the steppes of Central Asia. Of course. So George is a Greek. George is a Greek name. Yeah. Gorgios. And there's kind of various traditions about where he was actually brought up. So there is a tradition that derives from a manuscript that was found quite recently when they were kind of shifting monuments to build the Aswan Dam. And in this, George grew up in Nubia. But what the sources agree is that he rises very high in the imperial service, perhaps as a civil servant. But the general tradition, which becomes kind of canonical, is that he is a soldier, that he's a
然后他被放入一种巨大的空心青铜公牛中，里面同样有尖锐的钉子，公牛被转来转去，这样这些钉子就……总之，所有这些都非常可怕。然后在另一个记载中，他被轮刑架上的刀片折磨，这杀死了他。他被圣迈克尔复活，我们在上一集谈到过他，他是天使的队长，在伟大的战斗中与撒旦作战。是的。当他复活时，异教皇帝王国里的每个人都对伟大的战斗印象深刻。是的。当他复活时，可以理解，异教皇帝王国里的每个人都对他印象非常深刻。
warrior fighting in the armies of Caesar. So one of the institutions, one of the great institutions of the empire, either way. Yeah. So it's either the civil service or the army, and he becomes associated with the army. He is baptized and he is then ordered by a heathen emperor to sacrifice to Apollo. He refuses and he then just suffers tortures that are so hideous that they kind of verge on the comical. So in one version of the story of george he is forced into shoes that have iron spikes inside them he has his skull crushed he then has 60 nails hammered into it and then just for good measure he has molten lead poured down his throat he's still alive at this
所以他们都大规模改宗了。国王非常愤怒，继续试图除掉乔治。所以把乔治活活煮死，锯成两半，灌下熔化的铅。是的。乔治被圣迈克尔连续三次复活。实际上，如果你赢得了殉道者的桂冠，你就会直接去天堂。你会认为乔治会对此感到有点沮丧，但他确实在第四次尝试时，在 4 月 23 日终于赢得了他的殉道者桂冠。整个王国都改宗了，除了皇帝，但他的皇后改宗了。所以皇室的女性成员都改宗了。
point he's then placed in a kind of giant hollow bronze bull which again has kind of sharp nails inside it and the bull is kind of revolved round and round so that these nails are kind of giant hollow bronze bull, which again has kind of sharp nails inside it. And the bull is kind of revolved round and round so that these nails are kind of driving into anyway. So, so all, all very horrible. And then in another account, he is broken on a wheel with knives and this kills him. He's restored to life by St. Michael, who we talked about in the previous episode, the captain of the angels who fights Satan in the great battle. Yeah. When he's restored to life, understandably everyone in the heathen emperor's kingdom is in the great battle. Yeah. When he's restored to life, understandably, everyone in the heathen emperor's kingdom is very impressed by this.
不过对皇帝来说很公平。我的意思是，他坚持自己的立场。他坚持自己的原则。所以基本上，这就是殉道者的漫威版本。这是把所有关于殉道的故事提升到一个超人的水平。我认为这就是它如此受欢迎的原因。这就是为什么，你知道，知识分子、教权学者对它感到尴尬。在他们看来，这似乎是荒谬的、过度煽情的，而且有点威胁性，因为它使对教会如此重要的殉道叙事看起来有点牵强。但也使我们思考这些叙事的方式变得复杂，对吧？我们假设它们都是一回事。
And so they all mass conversions. And the king is furious, continues trying to finish George off. So boils George alive, saws him in two, molten lead poured down his throat. Yeah. And George is brought back to life by Saint Michael three times in a row. And actually, if you win a martyr's crown, you go straight to heaven. You'd think George would be getting a bit frustrated by this, but he does finally win his martyr's crown on the fourth attempt on the 23rd of April. And the entire kingdom is converted except for the emperor, but his empress is converted. So the female members of the royal family are converted.
但在该类型内，可能存在着与任何现代叙事中一样多的质量差异。换句话说，会有高雅端的东西。是的，这非常像是一个民粹主义故事，那种低俗的，殉道叙事中的《达芬奇密码》。是的，我想也许更像是一部超级英雄电影，对吧？因为出于某种原因，乔治已经成为一个吸引这类故事的人物。他吸引的故事越多，他就越成为那种标志性的殉道者。对。所有这些悬而未决的问题是，好吧，你知道，他真的存在吗？我认为这不可能说。
Fair play to the emperor though. I mean, he's sticking to his guns. He's sticking to his principles. So basically, this is the Marvel equivalent of a martyr. This is pumping up all the stories about martyrdom to a kind of superhuman level. And I think that's why it's so popular. And it's why, you know, intellectuals, clerical scholars are embarrassed about it. It seems to them absurd and over-sensational and kind of threatening because it makes the martyrdom narratives that are so important to the church just seem a bit far-fetched. But also it kind of complicates the way we think about these narratives, right? We assume they're all one thing.
但难道不能说，一个像这样的奇幻故事，仅仅因为它变得奇幻，我们拥有的奇幻版本并不意味着没有痕迹元素吗？故事一定是从某个地方开始的。要么你相信有人凭空发明了它，要么你相信有一个士兵改宗了，从那个卑微的开始，后来创造了一个奇幻故事。我想是这样。人们普遍认为，如果乔治真的存在，他最可能的背景是皇帝戴克里先对教会发起的伟大迫害。我们几年前为世界杯做了一整集关于他的节目，不是吗？他在 4 世纪初发起这个迫害，基本上是为了铲除教会。所有的来源都一致认为乔治是因为拒绝向
But within the genre, there would perhaps have been as much diversity of quality as there was within you know any modern narrative in other words there would have been stuff at the highbrow end yeah and this is very much a populist story those sort of lowbrow the dan brown of martyrdom narratives yeah i think a kind of superhero film perhaps more right because for some reason george has become a figure who attracts these kind of stories. And the more he attracts the stories, the more he becomes the kind of the emblematic martyr. Right. All of which kind of the question hanging over this is, well, you know, did he actually exist? And I think it's impossible to say.
异教神灵献祭而殉道的。他们也一致认为这发生在环地中海世界的东半部，那里的迫害最为残酷。所以我认为他很可能是在 4 世纪初戴克里先统治下在帝国服务中殉道的人。是的，我的意思是，即使是这样，（它）也一直有争议，但我会说这是最可能的，这是一个合理的最佳猜测，对吧？是的。所以除此之外，很难知道，因为当然，拥有一位著名的殉道者是一件，我的意思是，这是一件很棒的事情。是的，所以不同的地方都在争夺他。所以他最喜欢的一个地点是利达，也就是现代的洛德，就在以色列特拉维夫的南边。他的母亲被认为是负责该城市的科梅。
But is it not possible to say that a fantastical story like this, merely because it's become fantastical and the versions we have of fantastical does not mean there are no trace elements. The story must have begun somewhere. Either you believe somebody literally invented it from nowhere, or you believe there was a soldier who converted and that from that humble beginning, a fantastical story was later created. I think so. And it's kind of widely felt that the likeliest context for George, if he did exist, was the great persecution that's launched against the church by the Emperor Diocletian. We did a whole episode about him for the World Cup, didn't we, a couple of years ago? He launches this basically to kind of extirpate the church at the beginning of the fourth century. And all the sources agree that George is being martyred for refusing to sacrifice to
他的遗物被埋在那里。我的意思是，如果那真的是他的遗物，我们不知道。利达无疑成为了他在东地中海崇拜的主要中心。但必须再次说明，这方面的证据相当晚，而且你知道还有其他地方。所以约帕，海怪的巨大骨架被清道夫带到的地方。嘿，也许那个海怪，实际上是什么，鲸鱼之类的东西。是的，多令人失望。所以我正要说，这就是你的圣乔治和龙。正是如此，珀尔修斯在那里从海怪手中救出了一位公主，这似乎确实有乔治理论的回响。但同样，那个问题是这些故事要晚得多，而且似乎
pagan gods. And they also agree that this happens in the eastern half of the Mediterranean world, where the persecution was at its most brutal. So I would say the likelihood is that he is someone possibly in the imperial service who is martyred in the early fourth century under diocletian yeah i mean even that is you know it's been disputed but i would say that's the likeliest it's a reasonable best guess right yeah so beyond that kind of very difficult to know because of course having a famous martyr is something that i mean it's a brilliant thing to have yeah and so various places kind of compete over him so one favorite favorite location for him is Lida, which is modern day Lod, which is just south of Tel Aviv in Israel. His mother is supposed to have been the Komei who was in charge of the city.
不太可能有某种直接的连续性。我的意思是，我同意珀尔修斯和乔治之间非常非常诱人的相关性是耐人寻味的，但很难看出那个传统是如何迁移的。但我们稍后会谈到乔治的故事可能来自哪里。另一个耐人寻味的可能性是，我们得到的第一部伟大的教会历史是由一个叫尤西比乌斯的人写的，他是巴勒斯坦的一位主教，也是君士坦丁的传记作者。他写道，当戴克里先在尼科米底亚宣布迫害教会的法令时，尼科米底亚是现在土耳其的西北角，那是戴克里先的基地。伊兹尼克，以瓷砖闻名。
His relics were buried there. I mean, if they really were his relics, we don't know. And Lida undoubtedly becomes the kind of the main center for his cult in the Eastern Mediterranean. But it has to be said again that the evidence for this is quite late and you know there are other places so joppa joffa where the great skeleton of the sea monster was brought by scourers hey maybe that sea monster which was actually what a whale or something like that yeah how disappointing so i was going to say there's your saint george and the dragon exactly Perseus rescues a princess from a sea monster there and that does seem to have echoes of the George theory but again the problem with that is that these stories are much much later and it seems
是的。一个不知名的高级官员走到这个法令前，他把它撕下来并公开销毁了。尤西比乌斯说，这个人是尼科米底亚第一个殉道的基督徒，在被处决之前，他受到了残酷的折磨，他以令人难以置信的勇气承受了所有的折磨。所以人们认为也许这就是圣乔治。我的意思是，也许这是一个被认为如此英勇的行为，以至于这个人成为了这些故事的焦点。是的，一个高级官员，对吧？一个在帝国大机构中工作的人。是的。但我们真的不知道。
very unlikely that there's a kind of direct continuity. I mean I agree it is a very very tempting correlation between Perseus and George is intriguing, but it's hard to see how that tradition would have migrated. But we'll come to where the stories of George might have come from later. One other intriguing possibility is that the first great history of the church that we get written by a guy called Eusebius, who was a bishop in Palestine and a biographer of Constantine. He writes that when Diocletian had his decree announcing the persecution of the church proclaimed in Nicomedia, which is kind of the northwest corner of what's now Turkey, and that's where Diocletian was based. Isnik, famous for its tiles.
而且我认为我们不知道的事实正是他为什么是奇幻故事的绝佳焦点。他就像吸墨纸，只是把它们吸收了。当然，这就是为什么从长远来看，乔治出名不是因为他的殉道，而是因为与龙战斗。这是一个晚得多的传统。所以怀疑乔治的故事受到约帕珀尔修斯异教记忆影响的原因之一是，我们直到 7 世纪才得到任何关于乔治与龙战斗的证据。
Yeah. An unnamed man of high rank goes up to this edict and he tears it down and he publicly destroys it. And Eusebius says that this man was the first Christian in Nicomedia to be martyred and that before he was executed, he was brutally tortured and that he bore all his torments with incredible courage. So people have thought maybe this is St. George. I mean, maybe this was an act that was seen to be so heroic that this man became a focus for these stories. Yeah. A man of high rank, right? A man who's in one of the big imperial institutions. Yeah. But we don't really know.
所以到了 7 世纪，我们在卡帕多西亚的一座教堂里看到了壁画，乔治当然被认为是从那里来的。它显示他骑在马背上，他正在刺杀缠绕在一棵树上的一对蛇。一个世纪后，在北马其顿，发现了一块赤陶牌，显示他不是骑在马上，而是刺杀长着人头的蛇。然后到了 11 和 12 世纪，你开始得到关于他杀龙的第一个叙事记载。而且这些故事似乎起源于格鲁吉亚，圣乔治在那里非常受欢迎。是的，但格鲁吉亚不是以圣乔治命名的，对吧？
And I think that the fact that we don't know is precisely why he is such a brilliant focus for fantastical stories. He's kind of like blotting paper, just soaking them up. And of course, this is why in the long run, George becomes famous, not for his martyrdom, but for fighting the dragon. And this is a much later tradition. So one of the reasons for doubting that the story of George is influenced by pagan memories of Perseus at Joppa is that we don't really get any evidence for George fighting a dragon
人们经常这么说，在中世纪人们也这么认为，但令人失望的是，不，它似乎来自一个波斯词，这非常令人难过。这些故事然后被翻译成希腊语，然后在 13 世纪翻译成拉丁语。有趣的是，基本情节包含了所有原始殉道故事的元素。所以你有异教国王，你有被圣乔治救出的皇室女性，但现在当然它有一条龙，这让它变得更加、更加令人兴奋。那么我应该讲圣乔治和龙的基本情节吗？你喜欢吗？汤姆，我会的，但只有在我休息一下去打广告之后。当然。
until the 7th century. So in the 7th century, we get wall paintings in a church in Cappadocia, where George, of course, is meant to have come from. And it shows him on horseback, and he's spearing a pair of serpents that are twining around a kind of tree. A century later, in northern Macedonia, a terracotta plaque has been found that shows him not on a horse, but spearing serpents that have human heads. And then in the 11th and 12th centuries, you start to get the first narrative accounts of him killing a dragon. And it seems that these stories may have originated in Georgia, where St. George is incredibly popular. Yeah, but Georgia is not named after St. George, right?
所以让我们在这里留一个悬念，等待汤姆为我们讲述圣乔治和龙的故事。但与此同时，我们将听听赞助商的话。Chiara，在意大利语中意味着聪明。可惜你的咖啡师拼不对。所以你随便报个假名。你的咖啡馆名字。
It's often been said that, and it was thought that in the Middle Ages, but it seems rather disappointingly that no, it seems to come from a Persian word, which is very sad. And these stories are then translated into Greek and then in the 13th century into Latin. And what's interesting is that the basic plot has elements of all the original martyrdom stories. So you have heathen kings, you have female royals who were rescued by St. George, but now of course it has a dragon and that just makes it much, much more exciting. So should I tell the basic plot of George and the Dragon? Do you like that? Tom, I would, but only after I've had a break for an advert. Of course.
朱莉娅。但你用得越多，就越觉得自己在接受证人保护。等等。朱莉娅到底喜欢喝什么样的浓缩咖啡？现在改点拿铁还来得及吗？但如果你有一台 KitchenAid 浓缩咖啡机，你就不会有这些烦恼了。因为你完全可以在家自制浓缩咖啡。立即前往 KitchenAid.ca 选购。
So let's have a cliffhanger moment here while we wait with bated breath for Tom to tell us the story of St. George and the Dragon. But in the meantime, we will have a word from our sponsors. Chiara, it means smart in Italian. Too bad your barista can't spell it right. So you just give a fake name. Your cafe name.
我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《历史的余味》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余味》。汤姆，我迫不及待地想听听圣乔治和龙之间发生了什么。
Julia. But the more you use it, the more it feels like you're in witness protection. Wait a minute. What kind of espresso drinks does Julia like anyway? Is it too late to change your latte order? But with an espresso machine by KitchenAid, you wouldn't be thinking any of this. Because you could have just made your espresso at home. Shop now at KitchenAid.ca
我很高兴，多米尼克。既然如此，我将直接切入正题。是的，请讲。所以这基本上是最早的版本，它来自各种来源，但它们基本一致。所以有一个异教国王。他拒绝崇拜真神。所以上帝派了一条龙来惩罚他。这条龙，正如龙所做的那样，潜伏在一个湖里，造成了
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. Tom, I cannot wait to hear what happened between St. George and the dragon.
普遍的浩劫。国王的所有臣民都非常愤怒，因为他给他们带来了这个。所以国王建议每个人都应该献祭自己的一个孩子，试图安抚显然派出了这个可怕怪物的神。每天通过抽签选出一个孩子，献祭给龙。最后，抽签抽到了国王自己的女儿。每天通过抽签选出一个孩子，献祭给龙。最后，抽签抽到了国王自己的女儿，国王绝望了，不想牺牲公主，但每个人都坚持。所以公主被带出去留给龙。这时乔治骑着马经过，他从公主那里了解了全部情况。他说，太棒了，我要去对付这条龙。
I'm so glad, Dominic. In which case, I will plunge straight in. Yeah, do. So this is basically the earliest version, and it comes from various sources, but they basically agree. So there's a pagan king. He refuses to worship the true God. So God sends a dragon to punish him. And this dragon, as dragons do, kind of lurks in a lake and causes
但你需要相信我的上帝。是的。如果你那样做了，那么你就不用害怕了。龙从洞穴里出来。乔治接近龙。而且相当令人失望的是，他没有拔出剑。他画了一个十字。龙立刻被驯服了。
general havoc. All the subjects of the king are furious that he's brought this on them. And so what the king suggests is that everyone should offer up a child of theirs in sacrifice to try and appease the god who has obviously sent this terrible monster. And every day a child is chosen by Lot and sacrificed to the dragon. Finally, the lot falls on the king's own daughter. And every day a child is chosen by lot and sacrificed to the dragon. Finally, the lot falls on the king's own daughter and the king is desperate, doesn't want to sacrifice the princess, but everyone insists. So the princess gets led out to be left for the dragon. At which point George comes riding by on his horse and he gets the full story from the princess. And he says, brilliant, I'm going to take the dragon on.
然后乔治拿走公主的腰带，用它拴住龙，公主随后把它带回城里，城里的每个人看到这条龙进来都吓坏了，但乔治说别担心，一切都很好，你们所要做的就是接受，你知道，真神，一切都会变得很棒，他们都接受了真神，他们宣称对三位一体的信仰，乔治现在拔出他的剑杀死了龙，城里的每个人都受洗了。嗯，所以这就是基本情节，那里发生了很多事情，汤姆，但几乎所有这些都非常熟悉，对吧？我正在记下所有这些细节，我知道我们一会儿会深入探讨它们，但水边的龙、湖泊、定期的祭品、国王女儿的突出地位、腰带的东西、最后的改宗。
But you need to believe in my God. Yeah. And if you do that, then you need have no fear. The dragon comes out from the cave. George approaches the dragon. And rather disappointingly, he doesn't kind of draw his sword. He makes the sign of the cross. And the dragon is immediately tamed.
我的意思是，你之前谈到了超级英雄叙事。我的意思是，对于我们 21 世纪的流行文化来说，叙事基本上是现有叙事的元素组合，这太常见了，不是吗？这看起来显然就是这种情况，对吧？嗯，所以听过我们上一集的人会从希腊神话的故事中认出很多这些元素。而且我认为乔治的故事和那些希腊神话之间的联系，除了一个例外，不是直接的，而是通过基督教圣徒的故事在
And George then takes the girdle of the princess and leashes the dragon with it and the princess then leads it back into the city and everyone in the city is terrified at the sight of this dragon coming in but george says don't worry it's all fine all you've got to do is accept you know the true god and everything will be brilliant and they all accept the true god they profess their belief in the trinity george now draws out his sword kills the dragon and everyone in the city is baptized well so that's the basic plot there's a lot going on there tom but almost all of it is very familiar right just making a note of all those details i know we're going to go into them in a second but the dragon by the water source the lake the regular offering of a, the prominence of the king's daughter, the stuff with the girdle, the conversion at the end.
非常非常早的时候就借鉴了那些希腊神话故事这一事实来调节的。所以实际上有很多圣徒对抗龙。他们中的大多数不是军事化的。他们中的大多数是通过祈祷的力量或什么的来做这件事。我们拥有的最早的一个是公元 2 世纪末。我的意思是，那非常非常早。它出现在圣托马斯的生平中，怀疑者托马斯，他去了印度，那里的使徒。故事里有这个。他在印度。他发现一个英俊的年轻人躺在那里死了。
I mean, you talked about superhero narratives earlier on. I mean, it's so common to us in 21st century popular culture that a narrative will basically be a composite of elements of existing narratives. And that seems so obviously the case here, doesn't it? Yeah. Well, so people who listened to our previous episode will recognize a lot of those elements from the stories of Greek myth. And I think that the link between the story of George and those Greek myths, with one exception, it's not direct, but it's mediated by the fact that stories of Christian saints are
使徒立刻知道这一定是龙的作品。他刚得出这个结论，龙就从洞穴里出来了。龙和他聊了几句，说实际上他杀了那个男孩，因为他目睹了男孩和一个女人发生性关系。而这个女人是龙爱上的一个。而且更重要的是，他们是在安息日做的。所以龙在说，我杀了他完全是有道理的。龙是一个嫉妒的清教徒。
actually drawing on those stories of Greek myth from very, very early on. So actually there are loads of saints who confront dragons. Most of them are not military. Most of them are kind of doing it by the power of prayer or whatever. The earliest one we have is the late second century AD. I mean, that's incredibly early. It comes in a life of St. Thomas, Doubting Thomas, who goes to India, the apostle there. And there's this story in it. He's in India. He discovers a handsome young man who's lying dead.
是的。但圣托马斯不吃这一套。他让龙把毒液从死去的男孩身上吸出来，男孩复活了，龙身上有所有的毒液，它像气球一样膨胀并爆炸了，所有的毒液到处飞溅，这听起来可能不太像乔治的故事，但你可以再次看到有某种元素，所以你有一个在巢穴里的龙，他在伤害当地的人，圣徒到达，圣徒驯服并杀死了龙。
The apostle immediately knows that this must be the work of a dragon. No sooner has he come to this conclusion than out comes the dragon from his cave. And the dragon has a kind of chat with him and says that actually he killed the boy because he had witnessed the boy having sex with a woman. And this woman was one that the dragon had fallen in love with. And what was more, they'd been doing it on the Sabbath. So the dragon is saying, I'm perfectly justified in having killed him. Dragon is a jealous Puritan.
使徒立刻意识到这一定是龙所为。他刚得出这个结论，龙就从洞穴里钻了出来。龙和他聊了几句，说它杀掉那个男孩是因为它亲眼目睹男孩与一个女人发生了性关系。而这个女人正是龙所爱慕的对象。更过分的是，他们竟然在安息日做这种事。所以龙声称，它杀掉他是完全正当的。这条龙简直是个嫉妒心极强的清教徒。
Yes. But St. Thomas isn't having any of this. And he makes the dragon suck the venom out of the dead boy and the boy is restored to life and the dragon has got all this poison he kind of blows up like a balloon and explodes and all the venom goes kind of splattering everywhere and it may not sound much like the story of george but you can again see that there are kind of elements so you've got a dragon in a lair he's doing harm to kind of people who are local, the saint arrives, the saint tames and kills the dragon.
没错。但圣托马斯根本不吃这一套。他让龙把死去的男孩体内的毒液吸出来，男孩因此复活了。而那条龙吸入了所有的毒液，像气球一样膨胀并爆炸了，毒液四处飞溅。这听起来可能不太像乔治屠龙的故事，但你依然可以看出其中的相似元素：一条住在洞穴里的龙，正在伤害当地居民，圣徒赶到，最终驯服并杀死了龙。
And this is a pattern that is repeated over and over and over again. So I mentioned Daniel Ogden's great book on how the stories of dragons have emerged over the centuries, The Dragon in the West. And he has a list of over 200 of these stories. And the thing is, they're all remarkably similar. They're very conservative, the same pattern over and over again. has a list of kind of over 200 of these stories. And the thing is, they're all remarkably similar. You know, they're kind of very conservative, the same pattern over and over again. But this is why George is interesting because he is a warrior. He's a saint, but he is also a soldier. So Tom, just going back to that point and thinking about what you were talking about
这是一个不断重复的模式。我提到了丹尼尔·奥格登那本关于龙的故事如何随世纪演变的伟大著作《西方的龙》。他列出了200多个这样的故事。关键是，它们惊人地相似。它们非常保守，是同一个模式的不断重复。他列出了200多个这样的故事。关键是，它们惊人地相似。你知道，它们非常保守，是同一个模式的不断重复。但这就是乔治有趣的地方，因为他是一位战士。他是一位圣人，但同时也是一名士兵。所以汤姆，回到那个观点，想想你刚才在谈论的
in our previous podcast about the history of dragons, Christian writers in the Roman world, you know, no one has sort of said to them, there's been a massive cultural shift now. So the classical legends- It's part of their mental furniture, yeah. It's totally part of their imagination. I mean, they're steeped in that world. They're completely immersed in it. I mean, obviously, it'd be fanciful to think that they wouldn't be telling stories that would be infused with elements of Greek and Roman mythology. So the fighting of the monsters and all that stuff. I mean, I think that's right. Having said that, of course, they
我们在上一期关于龙的历史的播客中提到的，罗马世界的基督教作家，你知道，没有人对他们说，现在发生了一场巨大的文化转变。所以古典传说——这是他们精神世界的一部分，是的。这完全是他们想象力的一部分。我的意思是，他们沉浸在那个世界里。他们完全沉浸其中。我的意思是，显然，认为他们不会讲述融入了希腊和罗马神话元素的故事是异想天开的。所以与怪物的战斗等等。我的意思是，我认为那是对的。话虽如此，当然，他们
are aware that there's been a cultural shift because they have converted or they have been born again. Yeah, but they haven't dumped all their previous furniture, to use your expression. No, absolutely not. But I'm just saying that I think that there is an obvious Christian antecedent for this, which is the figure of St. Michael, who we've mentioned quite a lot already, the captain of heaven, the warrior archangel who fights a dragon. I think that's the kind of the obvious example. And the issue with that is that because he's an archangel, you know, he hasn't left any
意识到发生了一场文化转变，因为他们已经皈依或重生了。是的，但他们并没有像你所说的那样，抛弃了所有以前的精神财富。不，绝对没有。但我只是说，我认为这有一个明显的基督教先例，那就是我们已经提到过很多次的圣迈克尔，天堂的统帅，与龙搏斗的战士大天使。我认为这是一个明显的例子。而问题在于，因为他是一位大天使，你知道，他没有留下任何
relics. He doesn't have any bones. Right. Do archangels not have bones? How does that work? No, they're kind of, no. They're boneless, like Ramsay MacDonald. They're incorporeal. Right. Do archangels not have bones? How does that work? No, they're kind of, no. They're boneless, like Ramsay MacDonald. They're incorporeal.
遗物。他没有任何骨头。对。大天使没有骨头吗？那是怎么回事？不，他们是那种，不。他们像拉姆齐·麦克唐纳一样没有骨头。他们是无形的。对。大天使没有骨头吗？那是怎么回事？不，他们是那种，不。他们像拉姆齐·麦克唐纳一样没有骨头。他们是无形的。
Right, okay. So that's a source of frustration. Whereas with St. George, if you kind of, you model St. George on St. Michael, then you can have all the relics and it's kind of, he's more accessible, I guess. So I do think that St. Michael hovers behind these stories, but I agree that of course, if you live in particularly the Greek-speaking part of the Roman Empire, of course, you're going to be familiar with all these stories. And that's why perhaps the story of Perseus and Andromeda informs the stories about saints rescuing princesses or saving women or even young men, as in the example of St. Thomas,
对，好吧。所以这令人沮丧。而对于圣乔治，如果你以圣迈克尔为原型塑造圣乔治，那么你就可以拥有所有的遗物，而且他更平易近人，我想。所以我确实认为圣迈克尔在这些故事背后徘徊，但我同意，当然，如果你生活在罗马帝国讲希腊语的部分，你肯定会熟悉所有这些故事。这就是为什么珀尔修斯和安德洛墨达的故事可能为圣徒拯救公主或拯救妇女，甚至像圣托马斯例子中那样拯救年轻男子的故事提供了素材，
and that these then translate into the story of St. George. Well, because just think about how it would work, right? Imagine that you convert to Christianity when you're 20 or whatever. Presumably you're sitting there for the first, let's say, eight, 10 years of your life. I know that the stories are not children's stories in the same way that they are perceived as being children's stories today, the Greek myths. But there's no doubt that you would be told a story about Perseus and Andromeda or Heracles and his labours or Theseus and the labyrinth and stuff. I mean, of course you would. They're part of the common currency. It is ubiquitous as the Beatles music is today. So it would make sense that when you become a Christian
而这些故事随后转化成了圣乔治的故事。嗯，因为想想它是如何运作的，对吧？想象一下，你在20岁左右皈依了基督教。大概你生命的前八到十年都在听这些故事。我知道这些故事不像今天被视为儿童故事的希腊神话那样是儿童故事。但毫无疑问，你会听到关于珀尔修斯和安德洛墨达，或者赫拉克勒斯和他的劳作，或者忒修斯和迷宫之类的故事。我的意思是，当然会。它们是通用的货币。就像披头士乐队的音乐在今天一样无处不在。所以当你成为一名基督徒时，这很有意义
or when you really get into Christianity, your sense of what is, you know, the frameworks for the stories you tell are dictated by not just the Bible, but also the other tradition that is there at the same time. But I think that in the case of George, it's not like he's being modeled on the story of Persians and Andromeda.
或者当你真正深入了解基督教时，你对故事框架的感知不仅由圣经决定，也由同时存在的其他传统决定。但我认为在乔治的例子中，他并不是以珀尔修斯和安德洛墨达的故事为蓝本的。
I think that the elements of those Greek myths of dragons that live in caves and, you know, heroes fight them, that that has been kind of mediated and adapted by people who are writing stories of those Greek myths of dragons that live in caves and, you know, heroes fight them. Yeah. That that has been kind of mediated and adapted by people who are writing stories of saints who confront dragons. And then the massive innovation with George sometime around the sixth, seventh, eighth century is that he is a martial saint. He is a warrior saint. He's a soldier. Right. And so then that just kind of lights the touch paper for reanimating all these kind
我认为那些住在洞穴里的龙的希腊神话元素，以及英雄与它们战斗的情节，已经被那些撰写圣徒与龙搏斗故事的人所调解和改编了。那些住在洞穴里的龙的希腊神话，以及英雄与它们战斗的情节。是的。这已经被那些撰写圣徒与龙搏斗故事的人所调解和改编了。然后，乔治在公元六、七、八世纪左右的巨大创新在于他是一位尚武的圣徒。他是一位战士圣徒。他是一名士兵。对。所以这就像点燃了引信，重新激活了所有这些
of traditions and stories. And is that why he is on a horse? Because that is an innovation, right? That previously these people were never on horseback. Yeah. And I think that this is the thing where there might be a direct link between the Greek myth and the figure of George. And it's not a narrative. It's a kind of, it's an image because the image of a saint on a horse is something that does reach back kind of to, um, it's kind of, you know, fourth, fifth century perhaps. And it's something that's very popular in Egypt. And you have an unnamed rider who has a halo, his spear on the bottom has a cross and he is spearing a kind of supine serpent kind of lying at his feet and there is this inscription the one god conquers all and it's clear that this in turn
传统和故事。这就是他骑马的原因吗？因为那是一个创新，对吧？以前这些人从来不骑马。是的。我认为这就是希腊神话和乔治形象之间可能存在直接联系的地方。这不是叙事，而是一种形象，因为圣徒骑马的形象确实可以追溯到公元四、五世纪左右。这在埃及非常流行。你有一个无名的骑手，头上有光环，他的长矛底部有一个十字架，他正在刺向脚下仰卧的蛇，上面有铭文“唯一的神征服一切”，很明显这反过来
derives from the figure of a greek hero called bellerophon who rides the winged horse pegasus yeah and spears a monster called the chimera which in in the classical form, it's a compound of a lion, a goat, and a snake. This is an image that goes all the way back to archaic Greece, 6th, 7th century BC. But we know it's incredibly popular, even with Christians, because actually there's a mosaic found in Dorset at Hinton St. Mary. It's the famous one that people have probably seen. It's got a kind of beardless mosaic of Christ looking a bit like Apollo. But there's another one that's also in a kind of roundel that shows Bellerophon spearing the chimera. So this idea of a man on a horse
源于一位名叫柏勒洛丰的希腊英雄，他骑着飞马珀伽索斯，并刺杀了一个叫奇美拉的怪物，在古典形式中，它是狮子、山羊和蛇的混合体。这是一个可以追溯到古希腊公元前六、七世纪的形象。但我们知道它非常受欢迎，即使在基督徒中也是如此，因为实际上在多塞特郡的欣顿圣玛丽发现了一幅马赛克。那是人们可能见过的那幅著名的马赛克。它有一个看起来有点像阿波罗的无须基督马赛克。但还有另一幅也在一个圆形装饰中，展示了柏勒洛丰刺杀奇美拉。所以这个骑在马上的人
spearing a monster that is a symbol of evil, this is something that Christians seem to have been happy with. And I think that it generates image of a figure on horseback spearing a monster, and that this is why the stories of St. George killing the dragon are so instantaneously popular once he becomes associated with them. And although that image is specific to the Byzantine world, it's an image that emerges from the Greek half of what had been the Roman Empire. But you can also see why a martial figure on horseback fighting a dragon would have appealed to the knights of Latin Europe in the Middle Ages. And I think it's really telling that the cult of St. George starts to take off
刺杀象征邪恶的怪物的想法，似乎是基督徒乐于接受的。我认为它产生了一个骑马刺杀怪物的形象，这就是为什么圣乔治杀龙的故事一旦与他联系起来就如此迅速地流行起来。虽然那个形象是拜占庭世界特有的，但它是一个从罗马帝国曾经的希腊半部中涌现出来的形象。但你也可以看出，为什么一个骑马的尚武形象与龙搏斗会吸引中世纪拉丁欧洲的骑士。我认为圣乔治的崇拜开始兴起非常能说明问题
in Latin Christendom in the 11th century, which is when you start getting knights emerging as the kind of the shock troops of Christendom in the West, and particularly the Normans actually. So the Normans, they famously conquer England, but they're also fighting in Sicily, often against the Byzantines. So they may well have picked it up there. And there's an account late in the 11th century that the Normans are fighting the Saracens who were based in Sicily. And St. George appears before them in shining armor, carrying a white banner decorated with a cross. So is this where the flag of St. George comes from? The famous image of the white banner with the cross? That sounds very like the flag of St. George. Well,
在11世纪的拉丁基督教世界，那时骑士开始作为西方基督教世界的突击部队出现，特别是诺曼人。所以诺曼人，他们以征服英格兰而闻名，但他们也在西西里岛作战，经常对抗拜占庭人。所以他们很可能是在那里学到的。11世纪末有一份记载称，诺曼人正在与驻扎在西西里岛的撒拉逊人作战。圣乔治出现在他们面前，身穿闪亮的盔甲，手持装饰着十字架的白色旗帜。那么圣乔治旗就是由此而来的吗？那个带有十字架的白色旗帜的著名形象？听起来很像圣乔治旗。嗯，
is the cross red? That's the key thing. We don't know because the Normans, of course, lots of them go on the first crusade. And before the walls of Jerusalem, when they're attempting to storm the city, George is described as appearing to them again. And this time he's described as wearing white armor marked with a red cross. So again, that's kind of intriguing. Is the red cross on a white background? Is there something going on there with the purity of white and red being the blood of Christ or something like that? I suppose so.
十字架是红色的吗？这是关键。我们不知道，因为诺曼人，当然，他们中很多人参加了第一次十字军东征。在耶路撒冷的城墙前，当他们试图强攻这座城市时，乔治被描述为再次出现在他们面前。这一次他被描述为穿着带有红色十字架的白色盔甲。所以这再次令人着迷。红色十字架在白色背景上吗？白色和红色的纯洁性与基督的血之类的东西有什么联系吗？我想是这样。
Yeah. And so it's often claimed that Richard the Lionheart picks up on this and this is how it comes back to England. He's always shown in the flag of St. George on his tunic. But the truth is that actually that's not true. Oh no, Tom, don't do this. So shockingly, in the third crusade, it's the French who wear red crosses and the English wear white ones. Well, some of us think the French legally should still be wearing. I mean, you know, if only the royal family had the decency to press their claim, the French would be wearing red
是的。所以人们常说狮心王理查采纳了这一点，这就是它回到英格兰的方式。他的外衣上总是显示着圣乔治旗。但事实是，那不是真的。哦不，汤姆，别这样。令人震惊的是，在第三次十字军东征中，是法国人戴着红色十字架，而英国人戴着白色十字架。嗯，我们中有些人认为法国人从法律上讲仍然应该戴着。我的意思是，你知道，如果王室有诚意坚持他们的主张，法国人今天仍然会戴着红色
crosses to this day. I suppose. But I think what that suggests is that in the 12th century, certainly there isn't a clear identification of a Red Cross on a white background, first of all, with Crusaders per se, and secondly, with St. George as being a kind of a figure who can be associated with England. And it's really not until the 13th century. So that is when the tradition of George fighting the dragon has been translated into Latin. And so it's accessible that you start to get this sense that his arms are a plain red cross on a white field. Are we now into, let me just think about my medieval kings, we're now into the Edwards, are we? The 13th century? We are. So the English king who first adopts this
十字架。我想是这样。但我认为这表明，在12世纪，首先，并没有将白色背景上的红色十字架与十字军本身明确联系起来，其次，也没有将圣乔治视为与英格兰相关的形象。直到13世纪才真正出现。那时乔治杀龙的传统已经被翻译成拉丁语。所以它是可以被理解的，你开始感觉到他的纹章是白色底上的纯红色十字架。我们现在进入了，让我考虑一下我的中世纪国王，我们现在进入爱德华时代了吗？13世纪？是的。所以第一位采用这个
cross, this cross of St. George, the red cross on a white background as his emblem is Edward I. And he does it during his wars of conquest in Wales. The dragon. Exactly. So Edward had been on crusade. So he would be familiar with this. But of course, we talked about this yesterday, the dragon is the emblem of Wales. And so you can see how this would have gelled very, very neatly with Edward's requirements. But as we also said at the beginning of the program, it's actually Edward III with the Order of the Garter who really institutionalizes the place of St. George in the English court. Because up until that point, Edward I and Edward III's devotion to St. George was personal
十字架，这个圣乔治十字，白色背景上的红色十字作为他的标志的英国国王是爱德华一世。他在威尔士的征服战争中使用了它。龙。正是如此。所以爱德华参加过十字军东征。所以他会熟悉这一点。但当然，我们昨天谈到了这一点，龙是威尔士的标志。所以你可以看出这与爱德华的需求结合得非常完美。但正如我们在节目开始时所说，实际上是爱德华三世和嘉德勋章真正将圣乔治在英国宫廷中的地位制度化了。因为在那之前，爱德华一世和爱德华三世对圣乔治的崇拜是私人的
to them. But what Edward III does is to say, no, we're putting this at the heart of court ritual. And you can see over the course of the 14th century that this is starting to percolate out. So by 1385, during the reign of Richard II, the English are going off to fight against the Scots. And the ordinances of war that are issued for that campaign command that everyone in the English army should wear the cross of St. George and that if any Scot is found wearing it, then he should be put to death immediately. And I think that that suggests that you're starting to see a kind of wave of popular enthusiasm for it, partly because the story is so good. I mean, it's kind of very dramatic.
对他们而言。但爱德华三世所做的是说，不，我们要把它放在宫廷仪式的核心。你可以看到在14世纪的过程中，这开始渗透出来。所以到了1385年，在理查二世统治期间，英国人要去对抗苏格兰人。为那次战役发布的战争条例命令，英国军队中的每个人都应该佩戴圣乔治十字，如果发现任何苏格兰人佩戴它，那么他应该立即被处死。我认为这表明你开始看到一种大众热情的浪潮，部分原因是这个故事太好了。我的意思是，它非常戏剧性。
And also amazingly, because people do still think dragons are real things. Yeah. So a decade later, in 1395, there were reports that a fierce dragon is terrorizing large parts of England. I mean, it's amazing. So you can see why the stories of St. George would appeal to the king and to the kind of high chivalric element. But you can also see how it would have cut through with people who were afraid that there were dragons out in woods. So, Tom, we should have actually talked about this in the last episode, but just a tiny
而且令人惊讶的是，因为人们仍然认为龙是真实存在的东西。是的。所以十年后的1395年，有报道称一条凶猛的龙正在恐吓英格兰的大部分地区。我的意思是，这太神奇了。所以你可以看出为什么圣乔治的故事会吸引国王和那种高尚的骑士阶层。但你也可以看出它如何能打动那些担心树林里有龙的人。所以，汤姆，我们本应该在上一集谈论这个，但只是一个微小的
tangent and you just have to give me an answer. When did people stop thinking dragons might be real? There are reports of dragons, you know, as late as the 17th century. 17th century. I think it's around there. I mean, I don't think many people do then. With the kind of disenchantment of early modern Europe. Yeah.
题外话，你只需要给我一个答案。人们什么时候停止认为龙可能是真实的？有关于龙的报道，你知道，一直到17世纪。17世纪。我想是在那个时候。我的意思是，我不认为那时还有很多人相信。随着早期现代欧洲的幻灭。是的。
Throughout the Middle Ages, people do genuinely seem to have believed in dragons. Right. That was a tangent. But go on. Henry V is all over St. George, isn't he? Yeah. So Henry V is also, I mean, he loves St. George. And so when he relaunches The Hundred Years' War, we'll be doing an episode on Henry V
整个中世纪，人们似乎确实相信龙的存在。对。那是个题外话。但继续。亨利五世非常推崇圣乔治，不是吗？是的。所以亨利五世也是，我的意思是，他热爱圣乔治。所以当他重启百年战争时，我们将在夏天做一期关于亨利五世的节目
in the summer. Yeah. Great scenes. He, at Harfleur, the French port that he captures, he raises the banner of St. George. And at Agincourt, his battle cry is is in the name of almighty God and St. George. And this consolidates a view that if you're a successful warrior King, then you have St. George on your side. So you've got Edward I who conquered Wales. You've got Edward III, who's a massive lad. And you've got Henry V who won the battle of Agincourt. Against that, Edward II, who was useless,
。是的。伟大的场景。他在哈弗勒尔，他占领的法国港口，升起了圣乔治旗。在阿金库尔，他的战斗口号是“以全能上帝和圣乔治的名义”。这巩固了一种观点，即如果你是一位成功的战士国王，那么你就有圣乔治站在你这边。所以你有征服了威尔士的爱德华一世。你有爱德华三世，他是个了不起的家伙。你有亨利五世，他赢得了阿金库尔战役。相比之下，爱德华二世，他是个废物，
Richard II, who was useless, and Henry VI, who was useless. None of them had any time for St. George. No coincidence. And so I think you start to get an idea bedding down that if you are a successful warrior king, then you back St. George. And if you're a wuss, you don't.
理查二世，他是个废物，亨利六世，他是个废物。他们都没有时间理会圣乔治。并非巧合。所以我认为你开始形成一种观念，如果你是一位成功的战士国王，那么你就支持圣乔治。如果你是个懦夫，你就不会。
So then we get into the Tudors. Now, interestingly, the Tudors are kind of having their cake and eating it aren't they because they do fly the dragon because famously henry tudor lands at milford haven in wales he marches through wales he tries to actually mobilize a sense of welshness by flying his dragon and all of that kind of thing but basically they want to lay claim to both parts of the picture. They do. The dragon and the soldier. Yeah, they do. And I mean, Henry VII, he's got his dragons everywhere. And also, of course, he's famously mean. I mean, he never liked spending money on anything. And so understandably, his treasure assumes, well, I better cut back on the garter celebrations on
所以我们进入了都铎王朝。有趣的是，都铎王朝有点像既要又要，不是吗？因为他们确实展示了龙，因为众所周知，亨利·都铎在威尔士的米尔福德港登陆，他穿过威尔士，他试图通过展示他的龙和所有这类事情来动员一种威尔士意识，但基本上他们想对画面的两个部分都提出主张。他们确实这样做了。龙和士兵。是的，他们确实这样做了。我的意思是，亨利七世，他到处都有他的龙。而且，当然，他以吝啬著称。我的意思是，他从不喜欢在任何事情上花钱。所以可以理解的是，他的财务主管认为，好吧，我最好削减嘉德庆典的开支
the 23rd of April. And henry's furious about this you know he says no you know this is the one thing that we have to spend money on it's really really important saint george is the patron of england right and henry seventh is actually so devoted to george that in 1505 he obtains the saint's shin bone from the king of france so that's that's real commitment yeah and so it's not surprising then that Henry VIII, who loves his tournaments, who loves his flags, who loves his chivalry. I mean, he's a huge St. George fan. And he actually has an image of St. George kind of engraved on his armor. He's the first English king to mint a coin with an image of St. George on it.
在4月23日。亨利对此非常愤怒，你知道他说不，你知道这是我们必须花钱的一件事，这非常非常重要，圣乔治是英格兰的守护神，对吧？亨利七世实际上对乔治非常虔诚，以至于在1505年，他从法国国王那里获得了圣人的胫骨，所以那是真正的承诺。是的，所以亨利八世热爱他的锦标赛，热爱他的旗帜，热爱他的骑士精神，这也就不足为奇了。我的意思是，他是圣乔治的超级粉丝。他实际上把圣乔治的形象刻在了他的盔甲上。他是第一位铸造带有圣乔治形象硬币的英国国王。
And this is very well known internationally. So it's not just in England that St. George is coming to be seen as somehow the particular guardian. This is also something that is starting to get international currency. So in 1526, there is a pageant in Rome and Henry is portrayed as St. George. Now, of course, we know what's coming. So the Reformation is coming. But even when it does, Henry, he's not going to get rid of St. George. No. He's basically a Catholic. He just doesn't want the Pope.
这在国际上非常出名。所以圣乔治不仅在英格兰被视为某种特殊的守护者。这也是开始具有国际影响力的东西。所以1526年，罗马举行了一场盛会，亨利被描绘成圣乔治。当然，我们知道接下来会发生什么。所以宗教改革即将来临。但即使在改革到来时，亨利也不会摆脱圣乔治。不。他基本上是个天主教徒。他只是不想听命于教皇。
Right. And he is going very much with the grain of popular opinion. St. George is becoming a genuinely popular saint by this point. You have guilds dedicated to him. You have great processions on his feast day. Loads of portrayals of him going up in churches. Why wouldn't he be? He's fun. But also, if there are any remaining members of the League of Humanists or whatever they're called listening, the fact that he's not English is
对。而且他非常顺应大众舆论。到这个时候，圣乔治正在成为一位真正受欢迎的圣人。你有专门为他设立的行会。你在他的节日里有盛大的游行。教堂里到处都是他的画像。他为什么不受欢迎呢？他很有趣。但如果还有任何人文主义者联盟或无论他们叫什么名字的成员在听，他不是英国人这一事实
utterly beside the point because saints don't work in that way, right? I mean, he wouldn't be the saint of Catalonia, of Aragon, of all these other places if people were narrowly nationalistic about their saints. But I think it also makes him, in a way, slightly less threatening perhaps to the reformers than the English saints who for centuries and centuries have been particularly associated with shrines. So you think of Thomas Beckett, English, St. Edmund, we mentioned the Martyr King, St. Cuthbert in Durham, Edward the Confessor in Westminster. These are saints whose bones are in place because they are associated with the locations where they lived and died.
完全无关紧要，因为圣徒不是那样工作的，对吧？我的意思是，如果人们对他们的圣徒有狭隘的民族主义，他就不会成为加泰罗尼亚、阿拉贡和所有其他地方的圣人。但我认为这也使他在某种程度上对改革者来说比那些几个世纪以来一直与神龛特别相关的英国圣徒威胁要小。所以你想到托马斯·贝克特，英国人，圣埃德蒙，我们提到的殉道国王，达勒姆的圣卡斯伯特，威斯敏斯特的忏悔者爱德华。这些圣徒的骨头都在原位，因为他们与他们生活和死亡的地方有关。
And I think that that kind of makes them more threatening to Protestant reformers. It makes it more important that they got rid of. And that's why the shrines of all of those saints, to varying degrees, are attacked during the process of the dissolution of the monastery. So the shrine of Thomas Beckett is famously kind of publicly destroyed. Edmund's shrine is destroyed. Cuthbert's shrine is destroyed. Cuthbert's bones are reburied because they're still nervous of them. And Edward the Confessor, his shrine is destroyed. His bones are buried elsewhere. And then after the reign of Edward VI, people think, well, we can't get rid of Edward the Confessor. So he kind of lurks around. But with George, it's kind of different. The very unreliability of the traditions that everyone had told about him, all the stuff that
我认为这使他们对新教改革者更具威胁性。这使得他们必须摆脱他们变得更加重要。这就是为什么所有这些圣徒的神龛在修道院解散过程中在不同程度上受到了攻击。所以托马斯·贝克特的神龛被公开摧毁了。埃德蒙的神龛被摧毁了。卡斯伯特的神龛被摧毁了。卡斯伯特的骨头被重新埋葬，因为他们仍然对他们感到紧张。忏悔者爱德华的神龛被摧毁了。他的骨头被埋在别处。然后在爱德华六世统治之后，人们想，好吧，我们不能摆脱忏悔者爱德华。所以他就在那里徘徊。但对于乔治，情况有所不同。每个人讲述的关于他的传统非常不可靠，所有那些
had made Edward VI laugh actually makes him perfectly suited to the kind of the settlement that elizabeth presides over where you have a protestant church but with kind of catholic garnishing so here's the interesting thing that these people were real edward the confessor or thomas beckett let's say thomas beckett was a real person and so the existence of his cult and the existence of his bones or whatever to a reformer is an affront because they would say we know he was a real person he's a historic figure of course he doesn't have miraculous powers that's all total tosh yeah and of course he's an affront to the king yeah because Thomas Beckett was killed on orders of a king but with George the very fact that he's fun that he's a superhero you know that it's grey area, whether it exists or not, means that if you're a former, he's not so insulting. Because at some point you just say, come on, he's a bit of a laugh.
让爱德华六世发笑的东西实际上使他非常适合伊丽莎白主持的那种和解，在那里你有一个新教教堂，但带有某种天主教的装饰。所以有趣的是，这些人是真实的，忏悔者爱德华或托马斯·贝克特，让我们说托马斯·贝克特是一个真实的人，所以他的崇拜的存在和他的骨头或任何东西的存在对改革者来说是一种侮辱，因为他们会说我们知道他是一个真实的人，他是一个历史人物，当然他没有奇迹般的力量，那全是胡说八道。是的，当然他也是对国王的一种侮辱，因为托马斯·贝克特是在国王的命令下被杀的。但对于乔治，他很有趣，他是一个超级英雄，你知道，他是否存在是一个灰色地带，这意味着如果你是一个改革者，他并没有那么令人反感。因为在某种程度上你只是说，得了吧，他有点好笑。
He's an inspirational story. You know, no one's making great claims. I suppose his shinbone is a bit of a problem. What happened to his shinbone? I'm sure that must have been destroyed. But I agree. I think his kind of semi-fictional character makes him perfectly suited to not just the church, but actually the broad popular culture of the Elizabethan age. So the famous example of this is the Fairy Queen, the great epic written by Edmund Spencer, which opens with St. George, who Spencer calls the Red Cross Knight. And he is
他是一个鼓舞人心的故事。你知道，没有人提出什么伟大的主张。我想他的胫骨确实是个问题。他的胫骨怎么了？我肯定那一定被摧毁了。但我同意。我认为他那种半虚构的性格使他非常适合不仅是教堂，而且实际上是伊丽莎白时代广泛的大众文化。所以著名的例子是《仙后》，埃德蒙·斯宾塞写的伟大史诗，它以圣乔治开头，斯宾塞称他为红十字骑士。他被
commissioned by the Fairy Queen, Gl so aka elizabeth the first to go out and perform various deeds of chivalry including killing a dragon so he's clearly saint george and he is charged with looking after the beautiful and virtuous una who is clearly meant in allegory for the church of england yeah and the dragon that the Red Cross Knight kills is Catholicism. So, I mean, it's intriguing. St. George is, you know, if you are a stern, strict, puritanical, finger-wagging, hot Protestant, St. George is the worst kind of invented saint. But it still doesn't stop him being cast as the defender of Protestantism against Catholicism. So he's incredibly flexible.
仙后格洛丽亚娜（即伊丽莎白一世）委派出去执行各种骑士行为，包括杀龙。所以他显然是圣乔治，他被指派照顾美丽而贞洁的尤娜，她显然是英格兰教会的寓言。是的，红十字骑士杀死的龙是天主教。所以，我的意思是，这很有趣。圣乔治是，你知道，如果你是一个严厉、严格、清教徒式、指手画脚、狂热的新教徒，圣乔治是最糟糕的那种虚构圣人。但这仍然不能阻止他被塑造成新教对抗天主教的捍卫者。所以他非常灵活。
You can kind of make of him what you want. Is it also easy to make him a foe of Catholicism or champion of Protestantism because he's sufficiently far east, as it were, that he's not too deeply implicated with the papacy? You know, if he is from what is now, you know, Israel or he is from what is now Turkey. Yeah. He's kind of not tainted by Romishness. Yeah. And I think the kind of the locations of his battles are in a kind of fantasy land. Yeah.
你可以随心所欲地塑造他。他是否也容易成为天主教的敌人或新教的拥护者，因为他足够靠东，以至于他与教皇制度没有太深的牵连？你知道，如果他来自现在的以色列，或者他来自现在的土耳其。是的。他没有被罗马化所玷污。是的。而且我认为他战斗的地点是在某种幻想之地。是的。
So if you think of the famous paintings of him, the cello painting or whatever, you know, these aren't real places. These are the dimensions of fairy tale and myth. Yeah. And that in turn means that actually, if you want to to you can situate saint george's birthplace any place you want so there's a guy writing under elizabeth in the 1590s called richard johnson who writes a book called the seven champions of christendom which are various countries patron saints but saint george is the first one and he he is the dominant figure in this book and you'll
所以如果你想到他著名的画作，切利尼的画作或其他什么，你知道，这些不是真实的地方。这些是童话和神话的维度。是的。这反过来意味着，实际上，如果你愿意，你可以把圣乔治的出生地放在任何你想放的地方。所以有一个人在伊丽莎白时代的1590年代写作，名叫理查德·约翰逊，他写了一本书叫《基督教世界的七位冠军》，他们是各个国家的守护圣人，但圣乔治是第一位，他在这本书中是主导人物，你
be delighted to know dominic he is born in the midlands son of coventry yeah so actually you know he wasn't born in cappadocia he was born in coventry i think that's very plausible yeah i like that and of course the other reason why i think saint george gets cemented in as the patron saint of england in the elizabethan period and isn't jettisoned over the centuries that follow is that the 23rd of april his saint's day, is also the day on which Shakespeare supposedly is born and dies. Yeah. So perfect. England's national poets.
会很高兴知道，多米尼克，他出生在中部地区，考文垂的儿子。是的，所以实际上，你知道，他不是出生在卡帕多西亚，他出生在考文垂。我认为这非常可信。是的，我喜欢那样。当然，我认为圣乔治在伊丽莎白时代被确立为英格兰守护圣人，并且在随后的几个世纪里没有被抛弃的另一个原因是，4月23日，他的圣日，也是莎士比亚据称出生和去世的日子。是的。所以完美。英格兰的民族诗人。
Perfect synergy. Yeah. And I think that that's why St. George works as a patron saint, actually. I mean, the fictional quality of him is absolutely the point. Yeah. Celebrations of national identity or patriotism in England tend to be associated with either great royal spectacles, in which actually St. George doesn't really play any part at all, because it's all about the history of the institution,
完美的协同作用。是的。我认为这就是圣乔治作为守护圣人有效的原因，实际上。我的意思是，他的虚构品质绝对是重点。是的。英格兰的民族认同或爱国主义庆典往往与伟大的皇家奇观联系在一起，实际上圣乔治在其中并没有真正发挥任何作用，因为这完全是关于机构的历史，
or sport. And it makes sense to have somebody who perhaps didn't exist, who is occupying a sort of slightly grey, fantastical area. I mean, if Thomas Beckett or Edward the Confessor was our national saint, they would have been cancelled for some historic offence, wouldn't they? 10 or 20 years ago. Yeah, I mean, I think Beckett or Edward the Confessor, I mean, it would revolve around the royal family again. It would revolve around England's relationship to the crown.
或者体育。拥有一个可能不存在的、占据某种稍微灰色、奇幻领域的人是有意义的。我的意思是，如果托马斯·贝克特或忏悔者爱德华是我们的民族圣人，他们会在10或20年前因为某种历史罪行而被取消，不是吗？是的，我的意思是，我认为贝克特或忏悔者爱德华，我的意思是，它会再次围绕王室。它会围绕英格兰与王室的关系。
And I think, although, of course, St. George has always been associated with royalty, it's because of royal patronage that George comes to take on the status that he does in the English imagination. He's not dependent on it. And I think that the very fact that his story can be rewritten and retold in so many ways makes him very, very flexible. So sure, he has been adopted by the far right, but he's also a very ironic figure. The people who are dressing up in, you know, chain mail to go to football matches. Yeah. They're doing it in a mood of almost self-mockery. Totally they are.
我认为，虽然当然，圣乔治一直与皇室联系在一起，但正是因为皇室的赞助，乔治才在英国人的想象中获得了他所拥有的地位。他不依赖于它。我认为他的故事可以以多种方式重写和重述这一事实使他非常非常灵活。所以当然，他被极右翼采纳了，但他也是一个非常讽刺的人物。那些穿着锁子甲去参加足球比赛的人。是的。他们是在一种近乎自嘲的情绪中这样做的。他们完全是。
Yeah. It's fun. There's no political significance to that. Anyone who thinks there's a political significance to wearing a crusader outfit to go and watch England play Slovenia or something is demented as far as I'm concerned. But I mean, obviously there is a kind of slight element of an issue with the fact that he's associated with crusading. So you could imagine that Muslims in England might feel slightly uncomfortable with having a patron saint like that for their country.
是的。这很有趣。这没有任何政治意义。在我看来，任何认为穿着十字军服装去看英格兰对阵斯洛文尼亚之类的比赛具有政治意义的人都是精神错乱的。但我的意思是，显然，他与十字军东征有关的事实确实存在一点点问题。所以你可以想象，英格兰的穆斯林可能会因为拥有这样一个国家的守护圣人而感到稍微不舒服。
But he's not a crusader though. He's not a crusader. But more than that, he's highly venerated by Muslims. Okay, perfect. So Al-Tabari was a massive fan. He told the martyrdom story and kind of hyped it up even more. So actually, St. George is one of the few Christian saints who historically was highly venerated by Muslims. So I think he's a very flexible figure. And although I've gone on record, I'm not going to lie, I'd love to see St. Cuthbert as England's national saint. Tom, you're not going to win that one. Give up. No, I know I'm not. I'm not going to lie. I'd love to see St. Cuthbert as England's national saint. Tom, you're not going to win that one. Give up.
但他不是十字军。他不是十字军。但更重要的是，他受到穆斯林的极高崇拜。好的，完美。所以塔巴里是他的超级粉丝。他讲述了殉道故事，并进一步炒作了它。所以实际上，圣乔治是历史上受到穆斯林高度崇拜的少数基督教圣人之一。所以我认为他是一个非常灵活的人物。虽然我已经公开表示，我不会撒谎，我很想看到圣卡斯伯特成为英格兰的民族圣人。汤姆，你赢不了那个。放弃吧。不，我知道我赢不了。我不会撒谎，我很想看到圣卡斯伯特成为英格兰的民族圣人。汤姆，你赢不了那个。放弃吧。
No, I know I'm not. I do think that people shouldn't take it too seriously. What do you think about the sort of social media crazed humanist professors dissing St. George? Well, I think it's all part of a broad tradition. Again, you know, let everybody enjoy it whichever way they want. And of course, the irony is that as you so often say, Tom, I'm going to say it for you because I just, I know your methods. They are merely representing
不，我知道我赢不了。我确实认为人们不应该太认真。你觉得那些沉迷于社交媒体的人文主义教授贬低圣乔治怎么样？嗯，我认为这都是广泛传统的一部分。再说一次，你知道，让每个人以他们想要的方式享受它。当然，讽刺的是，正如你经常说的，汤姆，我要为你代劳，因为我只是，我知道你的方法。他们只是代表了
one wing of Christianity, aren't they? Absolutely. Well, it's lovely to see the presence of humanists following a great papal tradition. Yeah, very good. All right. So I think we can safely say
基督教的一个派别，不是吗？绝对是。嗯，很高兴看到人文主义者追随伟大的教皇传统。是的，非常好。好吧。所以我认为我们可以肯定地说
St. George is definitely a friend of the show. I think so. Yeah. And maybe the dragon as well. Yeah, we're like the Tudors in that regard. We're very like the Tudors.
圣乔治绝对是节目的朋友。我想是的。也许龙也是。是的，我们在那方面很像都铎王朝。我们非常像都铎王朝。
We're basically Henry VII and Henry VIII and I'll leave you to work out which. Yeah. Right. Tom, thank you very much for that.
我们基本上是亨利七世和亨利八世，我让你去弄清楚哪个是哪个。是的。对。汤姆，非常感谢你。
That was a forensic tour de force. Thank you, Dominic. Always a pleasure. We will be back next week with something very different. I don't know what it is. I'm sure it'll be amazing.
那是一次法医般的杰作。谢谢你，多米尼克。总是很高兴。我们下周会带着非常不同的东西回来。我不知道那是什么。我相信它会很棒。
So we'll see you then. Thank you very much, Tom. And goodbye. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews,
所以我们到时候见。非常感谢你，汤姆。再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们一起主持《剩下的就是娱乐》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、
splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
一点演艺圈八卦。在我们的问答环节，我们揭开了娱乐的面纱，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。